I have a dream made mistakes but
mistakes make you strong hey guys
welcome to our new fat to fit body
transformation in 12 weeks now last time
we covered the third and the fourth week
had no lust around three and a half
kilos which is a total of eight kilos
since we started this whole
transformation Wow
yeah that's a lot of weight 3 8 10
kilograms there's a lot to go around but
yeah I'm ready to go on you know really
make some extra cheesy tweets it really
cut down really get focused
really get some extra fat burn there's
about eight weeks that yeah yeah so yeah
already put so alright what's next so
the changes are we going to do for the
next two weeks the diet plan is
basically gonna stay the same just so we
get it haven't really used to this whole
new lifestyle change we're gonna add it
for you again in the video description
so you can go and check it out but the
workout routine we're gonna step it up a
notch and this is what we're gonna do
first you will start with the hip cardio
workout of 25 minutes on the treadmill
then the next day on the bike
and the next day on the rowing machine
but now we're gonna add the jump rope so
you're gonna jump rope for five minutes
after every cardio workout
[Music]
then after the hit cardio workout we'll
move to the weight training and it's
exactly the same as the last two weeks
but now we're going to add heat
exercises in between every weight
training exercise so in between every
set of your first exercise we'll do 10
seconds of high knees then in between
the next exercise you will do five
burpees and then you just repeat these
to hit cardio exercises throughout the
workout and in between the sets
[Music]
and I remember we have added harness
work at the teen the diet plan the
supplements he's taking we've added
everything for you guys in the video
description as a guide that you can
follow him with this whole
transformation series now let's start
this next two weeks Hannah are you ready
yep I'm ready I'm really pumped gonna
nail it and yeah but let's fast for this
yeah I did
[Music]
[Music]
two point eight kilos Wow and that
brings us to almost 11 kilos for the
last six weeks were right in the middle
of the body transformation yes so how do
you feel about that and the the last two
weeks yeah ten kilos is a lot I mean
that's a lot to carry ah that's us and
we can also see you're starting to add
some muscles as well which is yeah yeah
yeah actually I was a bit negative you
know about 2.8 yeah I would have liked
to do more but with the measurements
boiling fat and so on and yeah you know
so actually lost quite a bit of fact but
of course we gained that muscle as well
so sorry even so I yeah if you if you
guys are sometimes negative about not
losing enough weight just remember
you're gaining muscle as well throughout
all the workout such in doing so but how
do you feel about the diet as well yeah
and the workouts yeah you know well
actually on the muscle gain you know for
me it was a very big multivitamin um at
the beginning of ah do I need to do this
get up and go exercise but now you know
you can see that results so all the
little results is you can actually see
hmm helps with that motivation but yeah
so thought plan was good too like their
little changes that we made handy
of course we really go down some of the
things as well so yeah really got into
it and the exercising gym was good Gina
yeah really like to get a pump in there
and so on so that was criminal and what
did you learn you also learned a little
bit that we don't really need to eat
that much right huh so yeah I actually
learned well the three big things you
know that we learned was well by sick
like you said we don't need to eat that
much just overeating the other thing is
we actually have a lot of food stored in
our bodies yeah and the third thing is
it's actually very unhealthy fat is
actually helpful so the interesting
thing is a guy with 10% but in fact it's
got like 50,000 calories already in a
muscle in him that's food yeah
and inside four days about 2,000 yeah so
he's actually got that food ready to go
I got needy yeah and so the other thing
is you don't need to eat every day you
can learn fast and I eat every second
day and so on interesting thing there
was there was actually a guy that had
fasted for three hundred three hundred
eighty two days that's a long time for
fast yeah I mean he probably took some
supplements and some vitamins and stuff
as well yeah so yeah I had to drink
water of course some vitamins and girls
like you said and I think at the
beginning he was like 206 kilograms
Wow okay went down to 81 kilogram oh but
that's the thing you know I didn't have
to eat because he had that food to
consume that's already in this water
yeah I mean the other thing is of course
with health oh there's a lot of health
issues that comes with that store bag of
body fat especially with our insulin
levels and insulin resistance and things
like that so yeah and you know the more
you eat the more you have to eat because
you get insulin spikes you get even more
of it and go into insulin resistance and
yeah it needs even more so in eating
ourself to death but icicle II so higher
levels of that people get start to get
blind lose eyesight even yeah next thing
then is death and so on so and there's
some research on cancer cells at feeds
of sugar and stuff like that so my it's
Fatty's of real province actually the
more I read of it the more I see you how
bad it really is actually yeah you see
the truth I'm really proud of you
because I can see that you're doing your
own research as well and you're really
adapting to this new healthy lifestyle
because the thing is once you know the
truth of the food industry and what
you're doing to your body you start to
realize hi I cannot live like this
we can clearly see it not just your body
but also your mind the way you're
thinking and talking about food uh-huh
yeah and that's perception enough you
have really of what food is to us yeah
if you did not subscribe yet please do
and click the notification bar so you
won't miss the next video because next
week we're gonna raise the bar see you
guys next week
[Music]